Just want to end a little
bit talking about,
if you've got this way of recovering
depth, how do you represent depth?
That is, how do you think about
the representation of it?
We only actually talked about disparity.
We talked a little bit about
depth images but not too much.
But I want to talk about
just two quick methods here.
One is a depth image and then there's
a slightly more, I use the word nuanced,
a little more recent notion of
representing depth, namely point clouds.
So depth images as shown here this was
another one of those stereo figures
from the Middlebury
data stereo dataset and
this is a ground truth
known depth image, right?
So you see these rings here?
Right, well, you see that this one's
darker, and brighter, and brighter.
They're at different depths.
Likewise, this picture here
is this picture there.
It's brighter than this mannequin
back there because it's closer, and
if we had more grayscale resolution,
you would see this would be darker than,
than, than this area because the nose
is further back from the cheek.
So depth images have some
nice representations.
First of all,
I've got depth everywhere, right?
I can just go to every pixel and
say what's your depth?
So I've got a full dense
depth representation.
Something that's a little more subtle,
is that a depth image not
only tell you it's two meters
from here to that table,
it also tells me that between here and
that point is free space.
So it doesn't just represent the
surface, it also represents, by default,
if you will, that there is no stuff
between here and there, right?
So that putting the point
down there is also declaring
that the ray from my eyeball
to that point is free.
So it's a representation of both
the surface and of free space.
People don't make nearly enough use of
that fact but it's true and important.
The other thing is often we need to
think about depth discontinuities.
Well, depth discontinuities
are just edges in the depth image,
where we have lots of processing for
dealing with images.
There are, of course, disadvantages.
One is that it's very
viewpoint dependent, right?
I've got this scene geometry but my dept
image is based upon where my camera is.
So if I move over here, I've got
a different depth image, and combining
them is difficult because they're
in the reference frame of my image.
They're not in sort of some
natural reference frame
that talks about the object.
So it doesn't capture
the geometry quite so much and
the other thing is, if I want to think
about reasoning about the geometry,
I kind of need to know
where the camera is,
with respect to this, in order for
me to talk about where the geometry is.